[Music]
46 years ago martha moxley a 15-year-old
was murdered outside her upscale home in
greenwich connecticut the case made
national headlines and michael skakel a
cousin of the kennedy family was found
guilty of killing her and spent more
than 11 years behind bars but in 2013
his conviction was overturned now
moxley's childhood friends are speaking
out for the very first time they tell
our erin moriarty what they think
happened for this week's 48 hours
on halloween in 1975 in greenwich
connecticut fifteen-year-old martha
moxley was found beaten to death with
the golf club martha's childhood friends
richard burns and tori holland after she
was murdered everything had changed you
have no
sense of peace you've lost it all martha
was last seen with her neighbor 17 year
old tommy skakel the skakels were
cousins of the kennedys tommy's aunt
ethel skakel had married robert kennedy
in 1950. the skakels were also one of
the wealthiest families in the country
yeah that's a famous family they just
had a lot more attitude about you know
they could do anything while tommy was
an early suspect he had an alibi years
went by martha's murder became a cold
case and then in 2002 and 27 years after
the crime
do you have anything to say kennedy
cousin michael skakel convicted in the
murder of martha moxley tommy's younger
brother michael skakel was convicted for
martha's murder
prosecutors concluded that michael was
jealous of his brother tommy's budding
romance with martha but shortly after
michael was convicted robert kennedy jr
told us his cousin had nothing to do
with the murder i know michael skakel
and i know he didn't commit the crime
the evidence is much stronger in
suggesting that other people
may have committed the crime michael
skakel spent almost 12 years in prison
until his conviction was overturned on
appeal and kennedy says evidence
pointing to the real killers can be
found in martha moxley's own diary
and aaron moriarty joins us now erin we
just ended on the diary what do we think
is in this diary well i mean we took a
close look at this diary um like all 15
year olds she kept track of all the guys
that she would see
and investigators do believe that she
knew her killer so what kennedy is
talking about is this dance that she
attended three weeks before she died he
claims that she met a stranger there who
became obsessed with her who then came
back on mischief night and killed her so
we take a look at that entry it is there
we talked to the friends who i mean this
case really mattered and they remember
that night it's not quite the way
kennedy talks about it why is this case
been so hard to solve because it's not
like greenwich is a high crime area no
it's not it's a very small pool of
suspects gail it struck me it wouldn't
happen today think about it all those
houses would have had cameras of course
they would have had cell phone footage
they would have collected you know i
think that greenwich police were just
they weren't equipped for something like
this
all right aaron thank you very much you
can watch aaron's full report the diary
of martha moxley tomorrow night on 48
hours 10 9 central right here on cbs